ein virtueller vortrag geht zum thema
jenseits von italien fatalismus und
indifferent ismus fichtes begriff der
verbindlichkeit aufgrund von technischen
problemen habe ich ihn jetzt vorher
schon aufgezeichnet und bedanke mich
vorab schon mal vier mal als bayern
professor klemme für die einladung zum
vortrag in seinem philosophischen
forschungs kolloquium
ich freue mich einige thesen vorstellen
zu dürfen die im zusammenhang von
anderen projekten entstanden sind zum
einen der cambridge edition kanzlerin
kritik sondern vor allem auf die uhr die
zusammen mit john ford stehe ich auch
niemals grüßen möchte herausgeber in
diesem jahr und zum anderen im rahmen
einer 2016 in zweiter auflage erschienen
die situation die bestimmung des willens
zum problem individueller freiheit im
ausgang von kant die überlegungen die
ich jetzt vortragen möchte zur fichtes
begriff der verbindlichkeit gliedern
sich wie folgt ich werde erst etwas über
kant sagen und seine theorie der
autonomie die ich als eine form von
verbindlichkeit interpretieren
dann werde ich auf dem immer mehr
bekannter werden dem carl christian
schmid und seine theorie des intelligent
fatalismus eingehen der verpflichte wie
sich zeigt sehr zentral war zum anstoß
eigener gedanken und diesen
intelligenten fatalismus werde ich auch
als eine form von verbindlichkeit genau
von höchst problematischer
verbindlichkeit interpretieren dann gehe
ich über zur fichte und brannte ist
seine theorie der freiheit die ich auch
als eine form von verbindlichkeit
interpretieren wäre danach seine theorie
der moral dem moralischen
verbindlichkeit und schließlich seine
theorie der rechtlichen verbindlichkeit
bevor ich ein kurzes fazit geben möchte
dass die überlegung abschließt zunächst
zog als theorie der autonomie als
verbindlichkeit
kann sagte seine kritik der praktischen
vernunft lesen vor das moralische
gesetzt ist bei jedem endlichen riesen
ein imperativ der kategorisch gebietet
weil das gesetz unbedingt ist das
verhältnis eines solchen willens diesen
gesetze ist abhängigkeit unter dem namen
der verbindlichkeit welche eine nötigung
und zwar durch klose vernunft und der
objektives gesetzt so eine handlung
bedeutet wiederum pflicht heißt weil
pathologisch offiziere gleich dadurch
nicht bestimmte mit denen auch immer
frei ein wunsch 30 führt der ausflug
direktive nur sagen entspringt daher
auch im reinen objektiven bestimmung
gründe auf der gegenseite kann
und also eines widerstandes der
praktischen vernunft der innere aber
intellektueller zwang genannt werden
kann
als moralische nötigung bedarf hier sind
jetzt mehrere punkte wichtig ich habe
ein gefährt markiert einmal die
unbedingtheit des koreanischen sitten
gesetzes in seiner vorder und gegenüber
endlich lesen als wichtigstes
jugendlichen lesen keinen heiligen rein
vernünftig gewesen dann die
verbindlichkeit mit dem kant mit erkannt
diese abhängigkeit des verhältnisses
englischer wesen zum absoluten
sittengesetz beschreibt der begriff der
nötigung eines zwangs der roi nicht zu
verwechseln ist mit unfreiheit sondern
aus der reihe von unternehmen gerade im
autonomie bedeutet und einen weiteren
punkt auf den ich hier hinweisen möchte
ist der begriff des widerstandes der
praktischen vernunft der verkannt ein
ganz wichtiger punkt ist weil er
überwunden werden muss und zwar durch
einen intellektuellen zwar wir werden
ihren folgen dann noch einmal bei carla
christian schmid auf diesen inneren
widerstand oder dieses kindern ist die
carl christian schmid zeigt zu sprechen
kommen also ähnlichkeit ist nach kant
als auch die moralische nötigung die mit
einer gewissen objektivität des zwanges
zu tun hat wir werden sehen dass fichte
im folgenden sich
von einer solchen konzeption von
verbindlichkeit auch von autonomie
abgrenzt ein weiteres zentrales zitat
von kant was ich auch noch kurz vorlesen
möchte ist folgendes die autonomie des
willens erkannt ist das alleinige ziel
aller moralischen gesetze und derjenige
mesen pflicht alle eltern wird dagegen
nicht allein gar keine verbindlichkeit
sondern ist vielmehr der im prinzip
dieselben unterschiedlichkeit dass wir
uns entgegen
also jammers oder des willens oder mehr
vernunft ist endlichkeit
unverbindlichkeiten gegen die eternit
werke die nicht objektiv vernünftig
moralisch bestimmt werden kann
nun komme ich weiter zur carl christian
schmid und seinen intelligenten
fatalismus
schmid sagte in seinem versuch an
moralphilosophie von 1790 zitat wenn
unser verhandlungen das gepräge der
vernünftigen selbsttätigkeit an sich
tragen oder sofern eingegebene stoff der
vernunft vom gemäss bestimmt und
behandelt worden
insofern sind die moralischen und
unmoralische gegen so werden keine spur
von einer deckung der selbsttätigen
verläuft
darin erscheint wir können ganz
allgemein zu haben dass schweiz
installierter fatalismus ist eine
radikalisierung problematischer natur
der kantischen theorie deren autonomie
die von uns darstellen sagt folgendes
weiter dazu die vernunft ist das
gesetzgebende vermögen des menschen und
eines jeden vernünftigen wesens daher
bestimmt sie auch das urteil über die
abo diesem gesetz gemäß das sind die
anfänge des menschen des ziemlich
komplizierten wesens überhaupt sich zu
rechnet ihrer tätigkeit oder untätigkeit
obgleich die unmoralischen nicht von
ihrer wirksamkeit von der tätigkeit
anderen nicht vernünftige kräfte herüber
hier haben wir jetzt schon die erste
spur dieses hindernisses dieses inneren
widerstand das den wir schon bekannt
gesehen hatten
dieses hindernis der vernunft wenn die
vernunft nicht in wien bestimmt wenn sie
nicht verbindlich ist dann müssen wir
uns fragen wollt das kommt und schmidt
sagt das muss
von anderen kräften herrühren die mieter
vernunft einem konflikt stehen weiteres
zitat von schmid folglich dürfen wir
auch in anziehung der übersinnlichen
bestimmung grunde unsere handlungen
keine vernunft losen zufall
das heißt gesetzlosigkeit natur nicht
notwendigkeit annehmen es bleibt also
nichts übrig als gesetzmäßige
notwendigkeit es gibt schlechte links
keinen mittelweg zwischen beiden weil
sie einander kontradiktorisch
entgegengesetzt sind das heißt weil die
ganze wäre denkbar kite und möglichkeit
auf die begriffe von notwendigkeit und
zufall eingeschränkt ist das ist jetzt
ein zitat aus der zweiten auflage des
versuchs eine moralphilosoph als 17 2
machen sich also schmid ist hier ganz
eindeutig es gibt keinen mittelweg wie
auch johann wie auch ulrich der denker
dieser debatte argumentierte keinen
mittelweg zwischen beiden
man muss sich entscheiden vernunft loser
zufall und notwendigkeit
und jetzt kommt die definition des
intelligent fatalismus der integrierte
fatalismus dh die behauptung einer
allgemeinen notwendigkeit nach von und
gesetzen allgemeine gesetzmäßigkeiten
sich selbst in seiner ganzen gedacht
werden als domina ist ein notwendiger
gedanke der vernunft mit ihm alles
interesse und alle möglichkeit des von
uns gebrauchs steht und fällt also ihr
die definition der jäger fatalismus als
verbindlichkeit ist die flaute
allgemeine notwendigkeit nach von uns
gesetzten das problem dieses internet
und fatalismus besteht darin dass wir im
falle von unmoralischen handlungen nicht
selbst die ursache dieser handlungen aus
freiheit sind sondern dass wir gehindert
wurden durch eine der vernunft
entgegenstehen die kraft und das führt
dazu dass wir eigentlich spielbälle von
notwendigkeiten sind von vernünftiger
notwendigkeit oder von unvernünftigen
notwendigkeit
wir haben am ende glück oder pech gucke
jetzt moralisch schranken oder nicht
und das hat fürchtet seine kreuze
rezension von 1793 klar erkannt das ist
so einer der ersten schriften sich viele
freiheits erwartete damaligen zeit
er sagt zurechnung schuld und verdienst
fällt bei dieser theorie des intelligent
fatalismus nachher schmitz eigenen
geständnissen weg nun wäre es an ihm zu
zeigen wie man sich dabei noch je 1 1
für jede handlung nach dem gesetz
beurteilt wird gültiges gesetz denken
können die moralität welche übrig
bleiben soll ist eben diejenigen welche
in den ehemaligen glückseligkeit
unvollkommen als theorien übrig blieben
gut sein ist sein glück und böse sein
und wenn also das unmoralische vernunft
externen kräften zu verdanken ist
da habe ich nicht in der hand das heißt
ich habe glück oder unglück im guten nur
eines guten oder bösen
das ist so eine der boxen konsequenzen
sind dem fatalismus die fichte ja schon
sehr früh seine kreuze rezension erkannt
hat ein weiteres zitat aus diese kreuze
rezension pflicht des schreibens ist
ernähren freuen der kritischen
philosophiert und von reinhold
einleuchtend gezeigt wurden
das inzwischen derjenigen euro und der
absoluten selbsttätigkeit durch welche
den verlust praktisch ist und sich
selbst angesetzt gibt und derjenigen ich
werde der mensch sich in dieser funktion
sein wird bestimmt die sind gesetzt oder
nicht sorgfältig unterscheiden haben
hier sehen wir dass der wille häufig
denkt ins zentrum
nicht so sehr die vernunft dir eine
praktische noch bekannt sein der
individuelle wille der sich entscheidet
und zwar nicht beliebig seien aus
gründen der reinhold zumindest ein
anlaufpunkt
ich möchte in diesem zusammenhang noch
ein interessantes zitat von friedrich
schiller hinweisen seiner schrift
annotationen schiller steht auch in
dieser debatte und initiativen
fatalismus und er schreibt gebunden ist
er der an keine gesetze der natur aber
verbunden ist er mit dem gesetz der
verband das finde ich sehr sehr
spannende
wenn es doch zeigt dass der wille nicht
in different ist gegenüber dem
sittengesetz aber dass er nicht so von
ihm bestimmt wird die es bei karl
christian er entspringt im rahmen seines
intellekts fatalismus der fall war
der wissenschafts lenovo methot die dann
auf diese kreuze rezensionen alle
anderen schriften folgt nimmt sich jetzt
wichtig diesem willen mehr an und
bestimmte auf eine weise die sich von
der bestimmung durch kann auf eine
gewisse weise unterscheiden
das möchte ich jetzt mal nach zehn vor
dem hintergrund seiner theorie der
verbindlichkeit möchte schreibt die
erste verständlich haben kann ist die
aufforderung meiner als individuum zu
einem freien wollen das individuum ist
hier das entscheidende
in dem video jetzt aber nicht im sinne
eines empirischen individuums eines
kontingenten sind eines reflektiert am
bewussten individuums weiteres zitat
jetzt soll ein reiner wille zu grunde
liegen nicht eine bearishe wollen oder
verlangt überhaupt oder absolutheit des
vernunft reisen fichte unterscheidet den
rhein willen nicht nur von und
tierischen beliebigen wollen der ölh
gehört sondern auch von der reinen
praktischen vernunft überhaupt nämlich
der vernunft wie sie auch kant dachte
und diese carl-christian er später
besonders problematisiert in seinen
internet dem fatalismus der eine will
ist nicht empfehlen wollen und er ist
auch nicht reine vernunft keine
praktischen vernunft sondern steht
dazwischen
das scheint mir eine ganz wichtige
schlüsselstellung verpflichtet sein
weiter kommt er auf den willen zur
sprecher sagte diese bloße form des
wollens dieses absolute fordern und zwar
nach individueller identität dieses
fragen die du dir wollen ist noch nicht
das hinten gesetzt
das rein wollen wird hierbei fichten
nicht so gebraucht wie das sittengesetz
sondern nur zur erklärung des
bewusstseins überhaupt als er fürchte
fast dass reine wolle und die bloßen
form des wollens nicht bekannt als reine
praktische vernunft als moralisch
bedingt auf sondern als etwas
was davon noch zu unterscheiden ist und
zwar durch reflexivität jetzt aus dem
system der sitten wäre ein weiteres
interessantes zitat diesen zusammen das
nicht sagt fichte inwiefern es will gibt
als intelligent sich selbst das objekt
seines falls in dem es aus den meeren
möglichen eines wählt und die
unbestimmtheit welche die intelligenz
anschaue begreift lebt zu einer
gleichfalls gedacht und griffen an
bestimmtheit diesen widerspricht nicht
dass das objekt durch den natur- trieb
gegeben sein können es ist durch ihn
gegeben als objekte sehnens des
begehrens aber keineswegs des willens
das bestimmt entschlusses das zu
realisieren
in dieser rücksicht gibt es absolut der
will er sich selbst kurz der wille ist
schlechthin frei und ein unfreiwilliges
einkommen gehen hier sehen wir jetzt
dass fichte eine theorie des willens
entwickelt die ein sehr an diese
unterscheidung von first oder diesen
sektor relations verantworten da gibt es
eine studie von klotz oder auch von
anderen stolzenberg haben sich damit
befasst nicht auch in meiner
dissertation noch stärker unter dem
gesichtspunkt der freiheit also das
objekt kann durch die natur trieb
gegeben sein das objekt der begierde
aber man muss davon unterscheiden den
reflektiven willens der sich dazu noch
mal verhält und insofern nicht hätte und
nun bestimmt ist wir können es zu den
vorgaben durch die natur dem immer noch
frei verhalten das macht uns gerade
fallen diese auf dieses aufschieben
können von unmittelbaren bilanz
tendenzen und die freie reflexion r übt
das ist gerade das was findet ihr unter
diesen freien willen versteht so nach
während die glieder der synthes hat sich
den wissenschaftlern aber mit otto
vereinigten nämlich bestimmbarkeit und
bestimmtheit und das aufzuzeigen die
unsere erde mitglied wäre bei 3 in die
ferne mann ist ansehen bestimmen zeit
inwiefern man es bezüge auf das aus im
gegenteil bestimmbarkeit und liefert
neben eine wahl durch freiheit möglich
sein sollen also in der
freien wollen im rhein wollen haben wir
logischen momente nämlich die
bestimmbarkeit und die bestimmtheit
wir müssen ihm von der bestimmbarkeit
übergehend zur bestimmtheit und das
erlaubt uns die reflexion die vorletzte
male reflexion auf vorgegebene begierden
first oder designs jetzt komme ich
weiter zur fichtes theorie der
verbindlichkeit die moral das wird jetzt
etwas kürzer ausfallen wie ich das sagt
man sich wehren
der mensch muss um des gewissens willen
selbst brutalen das urteil an sein
eigenes gefühl haben
außerdem mangelt der moralisch
ungewissen lässt es gibt sogar
schlechterdings keinen äußeren grund und
kein äußeres kriterium der
verbindlichkeit eines angebotes kein
gebot kein ausbruch und wenn er seinen
göttlichen ausgegeben würde ist
unbedingt weil er da oder dort steht von
diesem oder jenem vorgetragen wird
verbindet da ist es nur unter der
bedingung dass er unter dass er durch
unser eigenes gewissen bestätigt wird
und aus dem grunde weil er dadurch
bestätigt wird dieses absolut fliegt in
nicht ohne eigenen besserung anzunehmen
seien erst an seinem eigenen gewissen zu
prüfen
und es ist absolut gewissenlos diese
prüfung es unter last gegen diesen
kategorien ohne ausnahme gültigen
anspruch treffen lässt sich
schlechterdings nichts vorbringen und
alle ausflüchte und ausnahmen und
modifikationen desselben sind geradezu
abzuweisen
also spricht bringt jetzt hier das
gewissen ins zentrum
das ist ebenso dieser dieses kriterium
der verbindlichkeit
wir müssen hier natürlich aufpassen dass
wir das gefühl von dem wichtige spricht
nicht als etwas beliebiges kontingentes
individuellen geschlechtes individuelles
verstehen sondern wir müssen jetzt so
scheint mir verstehen im rahmen von
wicht ist theorie des reinen wollen es
ist reine billens als eine reflexive
struktur die mit gründen operiert die
sich also selbst einwände macht und
rational vonstatten geht ohne dabei
gleich eine praktische von
die moralität eingeschränkt zu sein und
so finde ich müssen wir das gewissen und
das gefühl verstehen als eine kritische
abwägung von gründen die nicht a priori
schon mit dem sittengesetz
zusammenfallen auch hier scheint mir
können wir schon diese theorie dass ein
wildes als verbindlichkeit wieder denken
auch in seiner moralphilosophie noch
kurz auf seine verbindlichkeit nähe des
rechts sagt um den grund der
verbindlichkeit aller verträge zu
entdecken muss man sich den menschen
noch von keinen äußeren verträgen
gebunden bloß unter dem gesetz seiner
natur ist allerdings im gesetz stehen
denken und das ist der naturzustand hier
geht es jetzt wieder eine gewisse nähe
zu kant der seit die natur die
eigentlichen natur als das sittengesetz
denkt zumindest das bessere selbst von
dem kann spricht ein weiteres zitat wenn
die übernatürliche menschenrechte kein
vertrag stattfindet wird wenn nicht
stattfindet so bekomme ich durch vertrag
auf jemanden ein recht das nicht nach
dem losen sondern das gesetz nicht hat
und eher gegen mich eine verbindlichkeit
danach diesem gesetze ebenso wenig hatte
was ist ist das eben diese
verbindlichkeit auflädt sein will sagt
richtete nichts zu finden wo das
sittengesetz steigen als unsere eigene
rille mein recht gründet sich auf seine
verbindlichkeit mithin zuletzt auf
seinen willen aus denen diese sich
gründet hatten wir nicht zu bekomme ich
das recht nicht ein lückenhaftes
versprechen gibt kein recht an lasse
sich nicht durch die anscheinend die
härte dieser setzte schrecken es ist so
man darf sagen wie es ist die mobilität
die heiligkeit der verträge wird sich
schon unter unseren folgerungen zu
retten ist ich gebe ein versprechen da
geh ich habe wirklich den willen es zwar
lege mir mithin eine verbindlichkeit auf
und geben dem anderen ein recht also
irgendwie da hier essens der wille in
dem sich die verbindlichkeit des rechtes
gründet spannend sehen dass es nicht so
sehr die reine praktische vernunft ist
sondern wirklich dieser wille der aber
als ein reflektierter wille als ein
reiner wehle in diesem sinne verstanden
werden mit gründen ob
jetzt komme ich zum schluss meines
vortrags
was haben diese überlegung jetzt ergeben
über lichtes theorie öffentlichkeit
verbindlichkeit steht bei wichtigen
spannungsfeld absolutem vernunft zwang
und beliebigkeit des willens
also weder ist verbindlichkeit nachricht
der eine praktische vernunft oder gar
integrierter fatalismus noch die bloße
möglichkeit der natur sondern es besteht
die verbindlichkeit besteht eben
verhältnis dieser zweite möglichkeit
realisiert sich nur im freien vollzug
des individuums welches sich durch
reflexionen in beziehung setzt zwar aus
gründen und verbindlichkeit ist eine
relation des objekts gegenüber moral und
recht aber in letzter in sicht gegenüber
seinem reinen wollen selbst ich möchte
also zum schluss nochmals die bedeutung
des rheins verpflichtet betonen der
unterschieden werden muss vom reinen
wollen jetzt an vorschlägen dir eine
praktische vernunft aber auch von
anderen formen des wählens dieser zeit
die ihr an diese willkür erinnerten
diese bluse beliebigkeit der wahl mit
dem manchmal reinhold wie ich finde zu
unrecht in verbindung gebracht wurde
dichte nimmt eine zwischenposition
zwischen der internet dem fatalismus und
in different ist bei seiner theorie der
verbindlichkeit bedanke ich mich
vielmals für die virtuelle
aufmerksamkeit und ich stehe gerne bei
rückfragen unter der e-mailadresse
höhepunkt neue lz de zur verfügung
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen tag
und alles gute im neuen jahr